a lo que china ha venido demostrando
desde los últimos años de su por su
poderío militar desde todo punto de
vista hoy por hoy en la segunda fuerza
que más invierte en este aspecto y
aunque relaciones internacionales y la
diplomacia la guerra es el último
balance en el cual podríamos ingresar
evidentemente se trata de un momento
donde por supuesto se intenta establecer
un panorama donde dice china yo soy una
fuerza grande no voy a
enfrentarme directamente con eeuu pero
quiero mostrarle al armamento que tengo
y ha venido trabajando sobre todo en la
última década de caso que es bueno y se
puede esperar que este tipo de maniobra
se siga presentando como una forma de
retaliación
así es no solamente desde el punto de
vista militar sino cómo se presentaba en
la noticia del punto de vista económico
recordemos que lo que hace china
bloqueando siete de los puntos
principales a nivel logístico de taiwán
es también crear un poco un pánico a
nivel internacional porque recordemos
que taiwán es un exportador de cerca del
20 por ciento de microchips y cuando
hablamos de microchips más
especializados por ejemplo la industria
militar responde casi al 90% por ende es
enviar este mensaje nos llegan a hacer
acercándose a taiwán a este territorio y
respeten la resolución 27 58 del año
1978 y donde también se le dice a nancy
pelosi recuerde que los eeuu en el año
1979 firmó una declaración de una china
unida una sola china
bueno y eeuu decidió aplazar sus pruebas
rutinarias con misiles balísticos
intercontinentales que estaban previstas
para esta semana como se interpreta esta
decisión
es frente al algo que vemos hemos y xi
jinping ya había anunciado a baile la
semana pasada el lobo poco clarificador
y lo poco expositivo que resultaba la
visita de nancy pelosi a territorio de
taiwán y por supuesto recordemos en el
gobierno de bailén se está estableciendo
una estrategia que nosotros denominamos
autos es decir donde japón por supuesto
el último país donde llega la visita de
llegó a la visita de nancy pelosi
quieren establecer como un cinturón de
protección en contra de una china cada
vez más fortalecida en este ámbito por
ende lo que da es un mensaje de
precaución cautela y no encender más las
alarmas cuando sabemos que rusia por
ejemplo hay ha implementado un gran
apoyo a china en esta contingencia